hey guys merry christmas welcome to a
time lapse of the lego creator i'm not
even actually sure what this full set
was called but it's one of the santa's
little village it's extremely late right
now it's about 1am and we just finished
it merry christmas enjoy the video it's
1 20 a.m oh my god i'm so tired this
took a really long time it says expert
on the box
you don't necessarily have to be an
expert but
in hell it helps
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you enjoyed the video now we're allowed
to go to bed jenna i'm sorry so i'm not
done yet
jenna's not done i'm not a master
builder a few pieces
where'd that go um yeah i thought i was
gonna take an hour it's more like three
or four so merry christmas happy
holidays happy new year i'll see you
tomorrow i'm losing my voice it's time
for bed bye
ho ho ho